all right Stacey's where the Stacey's in
Milwaukee hi Stacey how are you hi Dave
I'm wonderful how are you this beautiful
Tuesday just the same how can I help
okay so I have a whole slew of stuff
I'll give you the background info and
then you tell me your thoughts
okay so right now my fiancee and I will
be getting married in next couple of
weeks yes
yay we have a little one who is 7 months
old tomorrow we have no debt outside of
our home fiancee moved here from
Oklahoma previously traded stocks during
the day but then once baby was born he
stayed home with baby so we didn't have
to pay any kind of child care well he
recently got his real estate license and
in order for us to really get the ground
running for him to really kick some butt
and do well we have to put the baby in
the daycare because I worked probably 50
hours a week with my job so that he can
really attack it head-on our goal is to
be able to live off of my income alone
because the key houses savings out of my
savings together we have around $400,000
what's it called $400,000 in assets so
our goal is like I said to live off my
income we're thinking either two we have
two things that we're thinking about
doing selling our house and buying a
duplex so that we can kind of live in
that duplex and have somebody else
paying our rent for us while he's
getting off with the real estate and
then the second choice would be for me
to lower the amount of money that I'm
putting into my Employee Stock Purchase
Plan and 401k for our week I mean we can
do both or if you have the other
suggestions newly married I would not
move okay and I would not have my renter
next door I'm not newly married you have
a new baby a new marriage and a new
career for him enough already
enough new already okay and I don't need
some things that you can count on and
the
that that address where you live will do
just fine for a little while so chill no
it's okay to own a duplex and have your
renter next door the good news is your
renters next door the bad news is your
renters next door yeah
and so in you know it's not always cut
out to be so no I would not do that
right now you have enough change going
on in your life I would just just chill
and just ride this thing out just let's
get his career going us make as calm as
possible and how much notice do you have
to give to jump in or out of your
employee stock purchase or your warm
winter 401k I can do that tomorrow
staff purchase plan it's a six month
period the thing is I have such an
amazing staff purchase plan my company
oh no I I promise you I do seen for some
off what with that it's 15 percent off
it's 15 percent yes 15 percent office
we'll call more abs but at the absolute
lowest price in that what they all are
it's many different than my elses and if
you look at the highs in the 52 week
highs in the 50 - we close on yours it
may move as much as 15% a year yes so
you know it's not really that big a deal
I would stop that I would stop that
anyway and I'm not playing single stocks
and and how much in cash can you get
ahold of that's not in a retirement
account um I have 25,000 in my mutual
funds and other investments that are not
in retirement accounts between him and I
like 150,000 okay so you got a little
pad that you could get ahold of if
something goes bad yeah I would not stop
your 401k I would stop the employee
stock purchase and I would not buy the
duplex I'm just trying to create as calm
a steady situation for a new marriage a
new baby and a new career okay so that I
can have more chance that he succeeds at
the new career so do you feel like it's
okay to eat some of the savings for now
okay you're going tired you don't think
I think if you stopped the Employee
Stock Purchase Plan you get on a budget
you get your every dollar calm jump over
and get your budget going the to you
this I think you can just live on your
income hey I'll bet you can what do you
make my base pay is 73 and then when I
get bonuses they can range I mean my
last bonus was $8,000 a bonus
pharmaceutical sales rep and home a
bonus Co every core every quarter you go
home on that you can live on that you
may not get to go out to eat as much as
you want to you may not be going on
vacation while he's getting this career
started but I'm not stopping your 401k
so you can do those things
get yourself on a budget you guys are a
little a DD we literally when I was
pregnant we completely redid our house
oh you don't need any more projects calm
down get slow and steady don't be the
don't be the hair be the tortoise you
couldn't be fine you're doing good stuff
you're gonna win you're obviously both
high energy people and you get a lot of
stuff done just don't put so much on
your plate enjoy your life a little bit
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
same room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you